there's always room for dessert here's a
sweet idea just for you
hi drew i'm capri lilly creator of good
food batty and today i'll be showing you
how to make these spooky pumpkin ice
cream cookie sandwiches here i have
homemade double chocolate chip cookies
and they're going to serve as the base
for our pumpkin ice cream cookie
sandwiches
right now i'm going to show you how to
make your own pumpkin ice cream at home
i'm going to start off by adding the
pumpkin puree
then i'll add coconut cream maple syrup
pumpkin spice cinnamon coconut sugar and
blend until it's smooth then i'll place
in the bread pan and place it in the
freezer for two hours and now i have
this delicious smooth creamy pumpkin
spiced nice cream now we'll take a scoop
of the ice cream
and place it on top of our double
chocolate chip cookies
and then use another cookie
to finish and complete the sandwich and
we're all done we have these spooky
pumpkin spice ice cream cookie
sandwiches
wow i'm in a delicious food coma just
for watching that
[Music]
you